find as the organizers to invite me I'm
going to repay their kindness by
lowering the tone of the meeting very
considerably and talking about some
slightly old work that I do I began in
an industrial lab in HP Labs some years
ago for very practical reasons to do
with understanding the relationship
between the investments in information
security technologies in the context of
large-scale systems so we were
developing some modeling technologies to
help us understand the costs the
benefits and costs of what we would do
however I realized recently that there
were some interesting logical properties
that might be coming out of this stuff
not so every visited this work a little
bit recently and I thought there might
be some small interest to to this
meeting in some of what's going on so
I'm what I'm going to do I just start
out by taking I'm sorry is the mic not
working it sounds to me like it is from
the echo but yeah barely hear you look
okay okay try that Zepeda ok I'll try
shouting so I well just did which is
review some of the background I can set
up that we used and it's not all that
complicated but it's surprisingly
delicate in places so what we started by
doing was just taking seriously what are
the kind of cool notions of distributed
systems so you go and get a big book on
distributed systems you read it and you
kind of reflect on it and we saw me
identify the idea of location which is
the basic underlying structure of a
system the other places where stuff
happens the connectivity between those
places the idea of resources stuff that
lives at locations and the idea of
processors that deliver the services of
the systems providing by manipulating
the resources that live at locations and
stuff like that what when you build a
model the system like this you have to
remember that sits inside an environment
and of course you're not going to
modeling environment environment it's
kind of everything else so you just want
to model that in terms of the events
that environment caused us to be
incident on the model you care about
ok now we were the business was about
understanding big complex systems
probably a quite crude level of detail
but we nevertheless needed to think
about how these things composed together
actually we're we wants to employ the
symptom minimal the minimal structures
that would do the job for us because we
were interested in in really quite
practical things that we were everything
I'm going to describe today almost
everything I went describe today is are
implemented and was deployed in real
systems work in hela packard some it was
even solved customers for actual money
so and just to remind you we were
concerned with practical modelling of
the relationship between security
policies and investments in security
technologies and the way in which
systems were constructed and used
locations we were working with topical
public structures of one kind of another
but mostly just with director graphics
they were simple and would do the job
the resources that we were working with
can be seen as being as arising from the
logic be is resource semantics which is
the logic and summit andrew and its
semantics that give rise to separation
logic which has recently had a great
deal of success in program verification
the process component was basically a
version of SCC s then was a ccs from 983
with just a little bit of refinement to
talk about how processes and resources
interact in particular I think Mike did
something a little bit like many years
ago but in particular I won't tell you
about it in detail but there's an
operator which generalizes restriction
in in a particular way to talk about
yeah now you recognize me yeah okay and
so an environment is just represented
stochastically I'm not going to talk
about that at all today okay so just to
see what's going on very quickly we're
talking about locations resources and
processes co-evolving via actions to a
new location you resource them and you
any process these are driven by in
practical models driven by a signature
of these see Skoob modifications
which tell you what a particular action
does to a particular resource I'm
actually to the pressing location from
here on that's because it just takes up
too much space to talk about so no you'd
also have locations here and you'd also
get a pair of resource allocation here
but just suppress that you can code
everything in location any results
anyway if you really want to of course
you can code everything your process if
you really want to but then you pay a
massive conceptual and computational
price that you didn't want to pay so but
just for presentational purpose that's
that excuse me let's let's just let's
just work with this signature which
tells you what actions do and I'm going
to just highlight a couple of key things
I mean this is a synchronous calculus so
we can work with how a resource and the
process evolving here and another
resource of the process of over here get
combined using concurrent synchronous
product and and and attention product on
resources to give you the new thing
similarly we've got a we've got a choice
operator going on and we do actually
need this other Combinator plus here for
a technical reason so this is where this
semantics depart from the semantic
separation logic in that we have these
two common astoria operations they have
to have a lot of laws relating how they
behave distribution those and so on it's
actually much closer to current
separation logic and separation logical
though even so the semantics is a little
different okay um that's a lot of the
safe from now there of course in the
sense of hennessy and owner and van
Penton these systems always come with
logics and this one looks a bit like
this so we here we can start with just
with classical logic on you can make
this intuition stick if you prefer but
everything gets living or complicated
then we can have some action with
galaxies and so far we've got handsome
your logic if you can then add star and
magic wand and then we basically got
separation logic at this point up to a
small amount of coding and then we can
get all sorts of exotic modalities these
are multiplicative modalities you can
also have multiplicity of quantifiers in
addition to a diff quantifiers I'm going
to tell you about any of that exam time
but the interesting anything to note
here is that this is kind of the
simplest thing I'm talk about Harry's
are kind of us
the simplest possible multiplicative
modality just talked about the
possibility of an action with respect to
additional resource now there's a whole
logical theory of how to set this up and
have lots of choices here with specific
additional resources and so on but
that's but that's just an example of the
kind of thing you can do in this space
again here you have you have the the
decomposition via by a star and there of
course there are some separation
conditions that I am bother to write
here and many of you know what they are
[ __ ] imagine what they might be okay
but this is the key thing this is a key
thing from the point this is as far as
the early days of this work when this
was the key way in which we kept control
over the decomposition of complex
systems okay just a funeral to the left
theory you what you want the idea of you
have the idea of logical equivalence of
processes just in case they satisfy the
same things always by simulation is try
simulation and the summer complete
result is the handsome of embedded
equivalents in this case it's really
this is really not as simple as you
might think if you try to do this using
the basic results antics that you find
in bi in separation logic it does not
work you get you only get completeness
for a fragments of the logic that don't
include a few multiplicative things you
can have star but you can't have magic
wand you can't have the modalities
nervous however if you have the
combinatorial structure of + + times I
introduced to begin with then you can
track stuff appropriately and get the
completeness theorem the doesn't appear
to be any expressive price in moving to
the difficult to resort semantics
anybody is it does lead to a slightly
different style of modeling the new town
okay so just a few more to this I just
made that remark
if you really want those three of this
said they're a bunch of papers in
journals like NSCs and TCS and DLC and
stuff we're all this has been worked
through in boring detail the main the
main point is that you do need this
combinatorial structure to track these
the choice operation under concurrent
projects as they evolve ok that's enough
maths now what about doing building a
bottle so the kind of mumbling we were
doing here it was good old-fashioned
mathematical modeling in the sense that
engineers do it right so women this is
not specification verification from the
ground up it was it was you've got a big
complex thing you observe something
about it you build some models you work
out what the models tell you check those
back in the real world and you refine
the model until you're happy with it
this is what engineers do now there's
everything I've said so far is
completely scale-free and in fact some
people are applying the kind of stuff
I've been talking about to weak memory
at the moment so it goes right down to
the bottom but this is the way in which
sees that this stuff is used is it's
it's the relatively subtle essentially
is important the reason separation logic
works so well by the way is that you
have you can build engineering models of
memory and its dynamics in this style
that but that happens to correspond in a
very strong way to a piece of logical
modeling that captures the scalability
in exactly the right way that's why
separation logic works all right these
two things come together okay so we did
it with you know we did a lot of this we
really did do a lot of this work into
the packer we did we did actually get
money for it and just recently we've
been it's come up again as a as a tool
that may be useful in lots of industry
based products that are coming to the
turing institute
okay so yeah this this especially
scale-free this is just an aside things
to remember when you're building models
the and that when I write in action I
don't care whether it's a great big
complex thing you're a really tiny thing
as a modeler you don't really you can
just choose to call something complex a
singer an atomic action or not and
everything will match that you're not
making any commitment to particular
granularity because of that you need to
choose your abstraction level very
carefully to fit the problem that you're
trying to solve with the coat so you can
answer the questions you want to answer
there's no good it's no good talking
about packet level network traffic if
you actually want to talk you actually
want to talk about the the costs and
benefits of a particular IDs device and
how many of them to scatter around the
network it's just the wrong level
abstractions ok in terms of
implementation most of this work was
explored predictions of the consequences
of policies and for systems using much
closer much closer sell simulations you
there is there are mom checking tools
available though they are a bit
restricted and not very well developed
and remember when you build models you
know the reason to build models is that
you want something simpler than thing
you started out with but that has
consequences also when you also remember
when you're building models sometimes
just better have a really crap model
next week than a really beautiful model
in six months time problem may have gone
away in six months time
okay so here's an example of the kind of
thing we might do is this is a very
simplified example to fit it onto the
slide and talk about but here are three
models big one in the middle is a model
of access control into a into a building
so the idea is that you come in from the
outside you enter a lobby and there's an
entryway which is perhaps card access
controlled and if you perhaps if you
entering you forgotten your badge you
have to go to reception to get a
replacement and once you've got you can
go back and go through into the inner
office and there are all sorts of bad
security things that can go on here
people can tell get you people can
people can steal your card and so well
you can get bored and decide not to
queue for a badge so tailgate somebody
else all sorts of bad behavior can go on
here so what sorts of questions do you
want to answer about this model you want
to answer about what is the ones the
right number of access of access
gateways what is the right number of
reception staff well it's the right
number of time it was there are timing
for various things that going on how
many guards do you need to keep an eye
on what's going on all these questions
are things security officers care about
so and they're quite easily answered by
simulation a static collections of the
system are is a model of the behavior
because up there you have behavioral
stuff and down there you have it's
basically behave you've got a bunch of
locations and at the locations live some
resources and what we do is you fire an
agent at it and see what happens as the
agent interacts with the resources that
are available you kick all this stuff
off by sarcastically firing an action at
the edge of the model and see what
happens that makes us so there's another
month here at which is the place you get
oh sorry the place you get to once
you've been what you get through the dr
the reception area you get into the
office where you could do all sorts of
stuff like print files and leave Leave
leave it USB sticks lying around for
people to steal and things like that and
then on the other side that's how you
get there in the first place where you
start at home you take public console
you take a car eventually you and you
leave you leave your laptop on the train
all that kind of stuff happens and
eventually you get to D to the to the
off
so these two people are smiling when i
talk about legal apps are some tracks
there no idea related rather just asked
you mentioned the idea of security
guards and people like that yeah you're
actually taking people into account as
well as the computation absolutely
absolutely sure people among the
processes basically yeah yeah you can
also moderns resources and which you
choose depends on exactly what you want
to do okay so facking this in this
particular model peak there are people
among those both different sorts of
people among both us processes and
resources so the agents who are doing
the attacker who are doing the
penetration the model idle are decently
religious too many anonymous processes
but the number of God's is just a
resource count for example most of the
resource measures eat mostly resources
you end up game modeled as natural
numbers and more natural numbers but not
always Peter memory is the audience okay
so the key what we really going to talk
about now are these little yellow boxes
these two things here the interfaces
between the models now an interface is
got what's going to happen is that we
got there has to be a shared location
that has identified as part of the
interface there has to be a bit of stuff
here and i can say that might be the
doorway has to exist in this model and
also just in this model and here perhaps
the stairwell has to exist in this model
and also exist in this month for example
so once you've got those two things
going then you can start to ask how do
we reason about the once you have the
idea you can also had we reason about
these sorts of things so interfaces they
have to mediate a compositional models
they have to build on the distributed
system structure we just talked about in
practice they have to involve the
locations that have to be locations we
talked about where these things sit you
have to take care of what egg results as
you expect to be there or arch and what
what actions are meant to be happening
at the boundaries this constants kind of
sounds obvious but believe me quite sure
okay and what's worth noting is that
when you when you connect when you
really put in
well in any case has to support is that
are a piece of the environment is going
to be supported is going to be replaced
by another model when you bolt things
together and that has to so that there
has to be consistency between at the
level of the the animation of the
actions which between what it looks like
when it's just the environment throwing
stuff and when and when it's actually a
model throwing stuff out of its output
so that's true so here's one interface
you look like there has to be a shared
location the idea is that these two are
essentially the same location so what we
do is we implement the distributed
systems on play with location graphs
they're good resources we explicitly
identify actions associated with the
identified locations in the interfaces
and then each model comes with a
specified set of interfaces models may
have many interfaces as I have to talk
to many different types of thing out
there in the world in different places
and so that in Davos specifying but now
connections and all the associated
actions that go with those things and we
need to have some detail generic
properties and the stuff I'm describing
to you now has committed to your social
city and stuff like that so it's kind of
basically kosher so now we so we end up
implementing models in a very direct and
simple way you're going to have a graph
with resource labeled vertices we're
going to have some identified actions
processes and locations that are sitting
in the interface and we actually and
those things are going to so those
things are going to sit in the specified
sets of interfaces and interface is
going to consist of destroyed impotent
applications which you might just write
like that these are the catered actions
so what's going on here then to remind
ourselves here's here's a model it's got
two interfaces associated with it this
one has an input location which is the
near the doorway this model also has an
interface in it has an input location
and output an output location which is
also the doorway this one here has you
know the stairwell which is shared with
this model which is a the input an
application for those two things and the
actions are the the actions here as the
agent goes through door action which is
located at
this is the agent edges the stairwell
action which is entered that the located
at so I told you is a very simple model
okay so in practice the moguls you
actually build or you know or you know
tens of thousands of lines of code in
the modern language do not going to bore
you with that don't you care at home
okay so the key thing I want to try them
quite quickly so that's good I want to
talk about those really down the the
frame property so what we want to do is
support compositional reasoning and what
a model m is composed of the model m 1
suppose mm to buy interface I one from
m1 and interface I to from m2 and then
what we want is a kind of frame rule so
think about concurrent separation logic
here it's kind of this stuff sort of
life at about the same time
synchronization so here's the ideas are
here's a property fire which holds a
bottle em before an evolution a occurs
and you become 0 blem prime to property
Phi holds science and that's what we
want to be able to do is to identical
reasoning about the properties of these
model these models sorry my phone
doesn't thicker ones so what we want to
know is that we can bolt together
another model n and another model n here
which has property KY and and preserve
the property Phi and insight that we
started out with so the course the real
way to read this rule is is as a rule
from conclusion to premises and you
computationally you want to start
deploying abduction as a way of
inferring product and waving furry
necessary components in the premises so
the conclusion is supported now the key
thing here is this little side condition
here and that that restricts the
evolutions that you're allowed to to
think about here but ones that support
the frame rule those are where you use
it said those those divisions are not
those actions are not part of the
interface right so that's important
right
the real salt as well just the immediate
transitions you could send up either way
depending on how much coding you're
going to do but yeah but in vain p which
is this right I mean it's not is this
what you want to do is say okay any
evolution occurs in the blue bit outside
of the other box has a property that is
fixed any bit that person the green Vic
that outside the other box has
properties fixed do sofa for this
yeah I got me on stage yeah sorry about
this my finger is really not doing wrong
so don't come yet okay so point is what
what this allows us to do is to restrict
when we bolt models together we want to
reason about whether or not the their
composition is well formed whether or
not we get the right properties of the
combined what we want we can restrict
that reasoning to precisely those things
that go on inside the interfaces that's
the be only bit that shank so we can
throw away all the reasoning about the
rest of the month which is the big
complex bit and focus your attention on
the bit that's going to call cause
trouble I mean anybody who works with
very large distributed systems will tell
you that all of the trouble comes to the
interfaces right and so what we want to
do is restrict the attention precisely
to those points so next steps here well
what we want there's a lot of refinement
of the definition interface on your
point their substance is personal into
that exactly what is the right way to
organize the data structure what are the
useful abstractions there is some
underpinning logical theory to be
cleaned up I mean so I only give you the
very slightest sketch of the kind of
logics that are possible here with this
kind of result semantics actually it's a
very rich theory i can give you pointers
to through developed in recent years of
that but there's a lot of it there to be
had in terms of implementation taking
abduction seriously so this is I think
you know about my friend Pete and does a
lot of work with Facebook these days and
they have this tool called infer which
implements separation logic for finding
bugs doing static analysis and their
adduction is a very very important part
of that theory and that what that does
is what that does is allow you to to to
run the framework backwards and
calculate appropriate conditions so
that's that's an important thing
that we don't really know how to do that
very very efficiently in the process
algebra worlds and we need to do I would
be lovely to do some more large-scale
applications networking electricity
supply changes and other obvious on
actually people are also thinking about
weak memory that meant it's completely
the other end of the scale and we used
to build some tools okay thank you so in
the a pitch that's a big it was up the
actual modeling the music is famously
where the key places where composition
is use that we visit to film things are
poor to take them apart or so he comes
into two eighths right when you try and
work out how to build models in the
first place you're staring at a big
complex system and you're working out
where the natural points to put these
interfaces are so that's the first place
hey how'd you decompose it you know what
are the natural chunks where the where
the frame rule is not is going to give
you enough restriction to make the
reasoning practical I think and then of
course once you've done that you're
reconstructing composition is where
decomposition e the properties of the
concert mobile is all so but to a both
ways are unusable so is it fair to say
that what you're describing here is a
sort of a temporal frame separation road
or do you think of this this temporal
your temporal version of the frame rule
you wrote you think of it as the same as
the special version which one is more
useful this is this is temporal yeah
because it's about current actions and
they are going on in there just ticking
along as they do but but yeah it just
focused on the action rather than on on
on pointers or whatever yeah yeah sure
could you give a specific example where
you use a production well abduction I
mean that's the dust the next piece of
work to do right so but I mean the place
where that's really kicking a cinnamon
is in the Facebook tool info so info is
an implementation of separation logic
intended to do static analysis for bug
finding I mean in this context of a
security what they are well so let's see
I might assert that I want to have so
here here I've got here I've got some
guy coming into a lobby and what happens
here depends on the presence of a number
of different types of resource you know
the number of security guards a number
of reception people the number of entry
ways sir perhaps the properties of
badges and stuff like that I might want
to put a efficiency constraint or a cost
constraint on the on the on the traffic
throw through this model right so that
would be a property in the conclusion of
a frame rule and in order to calculate
what I want to do is to calculate how
many guards how many entryways how many
how many receptionists I need in order
to achieve a particular cost constraint
so I would run I would run the rule
backwards and do some calculations to
find that
[Applause]